we called you in because your first
contact with figures was a disaster why
because our smuggling plan backfired and
she threatened to kill me yes every
single detail of what you just said we
need a new plan and at one I need
I need to step to her Amy this isn't
High School Musical yeah Amy this isn't
High School Musical too yeah and it is
an High School Musical three senior year
all right ladies and gentlemen we are
gathered here today to answer an age-old
question right what's Amy's deal is she
single no we're dating come on the
question is who here does the best
impression of Captain Raymond Holt you
will be judged on voice body language
and overall lack of flair everyone will
perform the same scenario Captain halt
eating a marshmallow for the very first
time let the halt off begin what is this
glutinous monstrosity before me
sugariness is quite sweet
that's your whole impression I can hear
him doing that looks like a stick
a sticky low I don't care for it
classical music what's going on here
what are you doing Captain hey nothing
just eating some marshmallows care for
one marshmallow
I know it I don't know
I'm just
I'm just sad
well I understand
must be very difficult
wait are you crying yes
thank you for acknowledging my feelings
thank you for acknowledging mine
we're both great at this
here we go
I'm bisexual all right I will now field
one minute and zero seconds of questions
pertaining to this go Amy how long have
you known since seventh grade I was
watching Saved by the Bell and I thought
Zack Morris is hot and then I thought
Lisa Turtle also hot the fact that the
words Kelly and Kapowski didn't just
come out of your mouth is lunacy what
made you decide to tell us now Charles
found it on the road trip and I was
positive he was not going to be able to
keep a secret for much longer bye Rosa
I mean not bye but bye I mean see ya I
mean have fun only having sex with men
just banging dudes left and right I just
stopped saying bye all together so are
you seeing anyone now yeah her name's
Tiffany are you lying about her name so
we won't look her up yes I am next do
you know Anne Heche I do oh I must say
this is going considerably better than
when I came out to my colleagues they
were not as the kids say awake do you
mean woke I didn't mean woke but it's
grammatically incoherent okay we have
time for one more question no no
absolutely not we're done
smart it was not tasteful there's
something I'd like to show you captain
Terry crushed it it works I've never
been more proud of you for anything in
your life I mean I've solved a lot of
cases for you and yet crime has
continued what are you trying to tell us
is this some kind of a clue
draw better we have no idea what this is
I think it's a cookie it's no it's a
pizza it's a cookie pizza another case
sold
no detectives sweet
let them go the math thing isn't the
problem night shift's keeping you and
Kevin apart you two just need a bone
what did you say
I said you two need a bone
oh
Dare You detective Diaz I am your
Superior officer phone what happens in
my bedroom detective is none of your
business
boom don't ever speak to me like that
again
[Music]
problem solved yeah
[Music]
um I just wanted to thank you for all
your help yesterday I didn't do much it
was nothing
good day
very busy
get back to work what are you having
there
a balloon arch oh my God Captain she is
magnificent
Vindication well it was good to see you
Caleb send me that info
wow he's leaving our plan worked we
saved our own honeymoon and fun bonus we
cheered up halt yes yes okay it's time
to celebrate you know what that means
this bee needs a c in her a oh my God
this babe needs a coconut in her arms Oh
I thought you were saying this music oh
my God that was my reaction all right
I'll go get us a couple of coconuts so
again your Alibi is a mysterious
stranger handed you the gun made you put
your prints on it robbed the store and
then hid the gun in your underpants Well
yeah if you say it like that it don't
sound believable oh hey Captain did you
get my report on the Findlay murder oh
yeah looked it over nice work good
thanks Dad
why is everyone staring at me he just
called Captain hold dad he said thanks
Dad what no I didn't I said thanks man
do you see me as a father figure Peralta
no if anything I see you is a bother
figure because you're always bothering
me hey show your father some respect I
didn't call him Dad no no no no Jacob I
take it as a compliment it's not a big
deal I called Vivian mom once and she's
my fiance guys jump on that Boyle has
psychosexual issues old news but you
calling Hulk Daddy hey Daddy is not on
the table here but you did call him dead
dude you shut up you've done nothing but
lie since you got here all right all
right I was lying about the holdup but
the dad thing that happened
he admitted that his Alibi was a lie it
was a trap all part of my crazy devious
plan I believe you thank you son
you want to talk about it later over a
game of catch
I'd like that I started seeing a
fertility doctor and she has me taking
hormones to help with ovulation and my
emotions aren't overdrive well I know
just the thing to cheer you up watch is
dead Bagel bago bago good news is our
evaluation will be done by deputy chief
Brandt we have a good rapport he was
once my captain so he's kind of like our
grand captain
that is amazingly funny
and that's your loophole I don't believe
in loopholes what loopholes are the best
remember that time when Pancake Palace
had that all you can eat deal but they
didn't set a time limit I ate pancakes
for a week for 3.99 all I had to do was
sleep there and never shower what thanks
for the invite friend I will not be
using a loop over Alta as always I'll be
using the main hole or no hole I choose
no hole he just said hole way too much
sir and that's coming from Charles yes
that's concerning oh you think you know
someone Jake unbelievable give me that
finger I'm gonna peppers for you pepper
spray me I will Pepper Spray you
hmm
oh God
crap crap crap crap Captain it's okay
there's nothing to be embarrassed about
I'm not embarrassed and I wasn't mugged
three men tried to mug me but I fought
them off injuring two of them
wait so you heroically fought off three
guys and that put you in a bad mood if I
did that I would literally write a song
about myself it would be like Jake the
hero abs of steel
why would you keep this for me and why
would you lie about going to fencing
because he couldn't go
because he's injured I wasn't injured I
was lightly stabbed I'm sorry you were
stabbed lightly stabbed we're gonna pull
this off we need to teach you how to
move talk and act exactly like Kevin in
other words we have ourselves a
Pygmalion situation exactly a big
mailman situation right it'll be okay
well it'll be okay let's get started yes
yes I heard it's getting worse spot on
Kevin look Raymond a yellow crested
warbler a craymond a yellow crested
warbler no you're too excited the
warbler is a common bird and then I said
which metamorphosis Kafka or Ovid
so that's the joke no you tell it oh
okay so a professor walks into a rare
books collection no you've ruined it now
it's not funny look Raymond a yellow
crested warbler look Raymond a yellow
crested word not excited enough they may
be common but they're still Burr the
92nd Street by had a wonderful Symposium
on just that topic that's it you're
getting it
oh don't say cool instead say indeed oh
indeed indeed indeed indeed indeed
that's weird look Raymond a yellow
crested warbler yes that's the right
level of excitement for such a bird
you've captured the essence of Kevin
you've done it correction I've
accomplished it indeed indeed indeed
indeed indeed indeed
it's growing on me all right fill me in
tell me everything I missed won't take
long only three things happened Terry
chipped his tooth and had a list for a
week listen up Steven
something amusing you answer me you done
number two Santiago and Boyle wore the
same outfit to work one day
[Music]
how does it look better on you and
Captain banned headphones from the
office due to the Gina incident
[Music]